Veronica 6 are you scared are you scared
Veronica are you scared are you scared
no no no no are you scared are you
scared Noel no are you
scared God I'm not a [__] like the rest
of these
[Music]
guys we're going to the line we got
front of the line
[Music]
passes
oh oh my
god listen guys I'm going to give you a
piece of advice you never you never
intake marijuana while doing
[Music]
this oh what is that oh your head oh my
God
Head knock
[Music]
knock
it
[Music]
slides oh
God so goddamn dark in
here since this is a horror movie you're
going to die
first come here woman oh
God
this way guys this way un this way guys
is everyone all right is everyone okay
for the most
part hang around now oh my God oh
my
it doesn't
[Music]
stop which one are you
talking taking me he taking
[Music]
me
w
[Music]
are you doing video
yeah all right guys well that's my Vlog
cuz I'm a YouTuber vlogging my life cuz
I can't just live my life I got to
record it everywhere I go yeah that's
right we we love to Vlog we're
vloggers like share subscribe you know
what YouTubers tell wo
[Music]
whoo